[Music]
let's talk about databases in AWS there
are a host of options to store your data
by using multiple database services in
AWS so quickly speaking you have RDS the
relational database service that
supports many engines then there's an
offering from AWS that is known as
Aurora it is a fully managed MySQL
compatible relational database service
then you have a no SQL service offered
from AWS that is a fully managed service
as well it is called dynamo dB
we are going to take a look at that then
you have redshift that is a petabyte
level data warehousing service again it
is a fully managed service then you have
ElastiCache that supports in-memory
cache two very popular engines such as
memcached and Redis then you have a very
cool service called database migration
service that basically allows you to
migrate your database from Oracle to
Aurora you can use the service and then
there is no downtime at all when you use
this service
so let's take a look at RTS dynamodb
ElastiCache and redshift so once you're
in AWS console you can see that this is
the RDS and it is a management service
which essentially means that batch
upgrade operating systems installation
are all taken care of by AWS then what
we are responsible for is when we store
our data we have to provide permissions
to set up the firewall settings and to
allow access for everything then of
course we are responsible for setting up
the databases but the engine is provided
by AWS
then if I click on this thing let's say
for example I want to fire my SQL
instance and if I click on this thing
I'll just show you how the high
availability as well as the backup is
taken care of by AWS
so I'll select my server my hardware
that's based on my workload and then I
can do something called multi AZ
deployment when I do this it basically
asks if you want to have a master save
configuration a high availability
configuration and when I do that then
yes I do get copies of my database in
the multiple availability zones within
the region and these are synchronized
replicated copies so in the event of
failure
I will automatically be switched on to
the other availability zone that has the
same copy of my database so let's
quickly add the DBE identifier and the
username and password so I'll just call
it my SQL for the sake of simplicity let
me just copy and paste all these
okay it doesn't like that okay so it
doesn't like my SQL database and let us
copy it all over
and then let's go to the next step
you
you
now when we go to advanced settings I'll
show you that they have something called
backup and then this backup is
automatically provisioned by AWS and you
can see here that there is a maintenance
window as well if I want I can give a
window then this is where you should
take my backup and the same thing for
the maintenance now these are all the
things that are taken care of by AWS and
in a traditional environment we have to
do all these things ourselves so this is
the beauty of using AWS that we don't
have to worry about the patches we don't
have to worry about the backup we don't
have to worry about the high
availability
it's just configured and all we have to
do is set some security rules some
firewall rules and some accessibility
rules for the users coming back to the
no SQL offering of AWS so this is Amazon
DynamoDB again it is a very fast and
flexible no SQL database so for all of
your IOT platforms for your mobile for
your gaming this is the AWS service that
you are going to use because it is a
schema 'less database essentially where
you can have a keep add value and you
don't have to worry about whether I'm
going to store one value or do I have to
store values and all columns as well it
deals in something called read capacity
unit and right capacity unit for your
read requirement and for your write
requirement and that's how it works you
don't have to worry about the
provisioning of resources it's scales
automatically redshift is a petabyte
scale data warehousing solution and
again it is a managed service so you
don't have to worry about you know the
OS level or the patches the same thing
goes with ElastiCache as well it
supports the very popular memcache and
Redis engines and it is a fully managed
service so you don't have to worry about
management or scaling of all of the
memory in these engines
hey once become an expert in cloud
computing then subscribe to simpler
Channel and click here to watch more
such videos turn it up and get certified
in cloud computing click here